we'll now check in on today's covid
numbers nevada reporting more than 1200
new cases
and 10 deaths in its daily report the
high numbers are similar to the large
case
loads reported back in july the
positivity rate
11.7 percent hospitalizations up by 44
today
clark county does remain in the red on
the county criteria tracker with
769 new cases and six new deaths
reported
the recovery rate has gone down slightly
since last week but still
relatively high there at nearly 90
percent
the u.s set another record for
coronavirus cases more than a hundred
thousand in a single day
and for the second day in a row more
than one thousand deaths were reported
wednesday new infections are increasing
in nearly every state with
hospitals in some areas reaching a
breaking point
here's elise preston with more from new
york city
coronavirus cases in el paso texas are
skyrocketing
one health official says hospitals are
near a breaking point
with more than one thousand covet 19
hospitalizations
reported wednesday it's just important
for this community to understand
that what we're doing is failing the
state has sent nurses and medical beds
to el paso and the convention center has
become
a field hospital new infections are
increasing
in nearly every state and more than 1
000 deaths were reported wednesday
for the second straight day dr william
shafner is an infectious diseases doctor
at vanderbilt university medical center
we can reverse the trend if we wear
masks
observe social distancing and avoid
large group events
do good hand hygiene here in new york
the city is again
using its hyper local approach sending
new testing
contact tracing and outreach into
affected neighborhoods
that approach worked and that approach
is what we will employ
anytime we see a problem going forward
alabama governor kay ivey extended her
statewide mass mandate through december
11.
sooner rather than later it's going to
be up to each of us to do the right
thing
ohio nurse practitioner tamu brown was
diagnosed this week
if i'm being honest i got a little
comfortable you know we're eight months
in
and i think that i was kind of a little
more comfortable
visiting people doing things experts say
it's important to fight pandemic fatigue
especially heading into the winter
months elise preston
cbs news new york